hallo zusammen das sind eure Fragen und
eure Reportage und zu Wikingern
wenn man ist online kostümversand
igitt Wikinger dann
genauso
historisch und akkurat das hat mit der
Ranzen verzählt es wäre extreme Material
verschwendet und unnötig und man hat es
einfach auch nicht gefunden
und genau so ist es auch mit der
Kampfszene der Reportage
das Wikinger nicht immer nur kämpft
haben
sondern eben auch das Handwerk und das
bürgerliche Leben kann und darum haben
wir uns entschieden
vs Freak geschrieben
kein zweiter Teil aber will ich die
Szene auch sehr cool finde
also nicht mit Ungarn dir
das heißt wie so einen Kampf hätte
und dann mache ich es dann ernst worden
das heißt mir ein Freestyles recht ich
fahre wie physisch das sonnenkampffisch
also nach 6 Sekunden hätte ich schon die
erste Schnittverletzung wenn jetzt das
Messer geschliffen und nach zwei Minuten
bin ich schon erschöpfigt
[Applaus]
mehrere Minute oder Stunde kämpft hat
wieder eine Mittelalter Film sondern oft
schon noch weniger Sekunden entschieden
sie sind ein weiterer kommentarisch
innerhalb von 2020 sehr cool ausbauen
Kroatien wäre auch mega lässig zu sehen
Liebe darauf oder lieber
ich schalte jetzt nämlich gerade zum
Runterladen er ist aktuell gerade im in
der Bauphase und vielleicht kann ein
bisschen zeigen
und dann auch auf die ein oder andere
Kommentare egal
wo bist du
wie läuft's mit dem Fußball mit einem
Wikingerdorf
sehr schön los haben wir mal das Gerüst
gestellt und traumhaft Badezuber besorgt
die wir jetzt noch reinigen und
ausstellen müssen
wir bauen unser Haus vielleicht ist das
am Ende des Ferienhütte vielleicht
ist vielleicht ist das irgendwann unsere
Altersvorsorge der gegeben wollen also
wir wissen es nicht wir machen einfach
einfach machen
sehr gut
apropos machen ich kann das Paar
Kommentar wurde Reportage vor sind wo du
besser hast beantwortet als ich die
erste Frage und ich dir gern für Stelle
und vom Franz-Josef 50 58 er schreibt
top Wikinger Verein Frage sind die
Wikinger im Winter auch draußen ich sehe
das Büro
tatsächlich schon also du hast ja schon
die nachbarlagergruppe kennengelernt die
Kollegen Bastis und die haben Beispiel
im Winter schon eine Woche privat Lager
gemacht mitten im Schnee wo es geschneit
hat und tatsächlich ist es im Winter gar
nicht also es ist härter definitiv ich
will da nichts romantisieren aber es ist
natürlich so dass man auch früher in
Norwegen schon im Winter überlebt hat
und natürlich möchte man dieses Feeling
ja auch irgendwie haben ich möchte
gerade zum nächste Kommentar Garde
Daniel Severin 587 geschickt eine schöne
Doku und äußere sympathische Menschen
aber als Living History Darsteller muss
ich trotzdem sagen dass etwas schade ist
dass man das Gefühl bekommt dass die
Wikinger wirklich so aussehen und lebten
schön dass einzelne Details tatsächlich
historisch sind aber vieles ist eher
Fantasie
doch also
immer offen für Kritik offen für
Vorschläge wir sind wasserstoff kann man
ja vorbeikommen sind da wirklich offen
für Tipps versuchen uns zu verbessern
aber ich würde definitiv nicht sagen
dass das Fantasy ist auf keinen Fall
aber in so einer Doku ist natürlich
schwer rüberzubringen welches Lager
gehört wohin und also es gibt immer was
zu finden und gerade bei uns als junge
Gruppe gibt es noch ein bisschen mehr zu
finden
aber wir nehmen das ganze wie gesagt
wirklich sehr sehr ernst und
Fantasy ist es definitiv nicht
an das heißt wenn man sich selber wird
das Bild machen wie historisch dass er
sind und so mit dem Finger zeigen will
ist dass ich einmal für Bücher in
baselsdorf
absolut cool sehr cool hey danke viel
mal für das Gespräch tschüss
ein weiterer kommentarisch
wo kann man sich informieren wann diese
Märkte in Lichtenstein veranstaltet
werden also es gibt es heute die heißt
mirimore.ch und das hat so einen
Kalender wo alle aufgelistet sind
in der Schweiz und in Liechtenstein aber
unter dem Kommentar hat aber beantwortet
dass der Mittelaltermarkt in
schallerberg der nicht immer aufgelistet
ist
hast du direkt auf Homepage gerade
stattfindet ich möchte noch letzte
Kommentar Vorlesen vom
Griechenland bin jedes Jahr am
wenigstens eine mittelalterliche
veranstaltet große Fan von der
Atmosphäre und die Musik der nächste
märz bei mir ist Bums
dass ich ganzen spezielle
Mittelaltermarkt und zwar dünnstete
fiktifisch lachte also das ist zum
Beispiel Wikinger
gerichtet und ich habe mich auch schon
bereit ob ich als nächstes Jahr
teilnehmen aber was danke dir findet
eine andere Frage zu Reportage könnte
natürlich der ohne neue Kommentare
geschrieben